Sheet feeder without feed rolls.
No crushing of boards and protection of material...
...when feeding into the machine.
New developed vacuum sheet transport minimized wear operation...
...over extremely long periods.
No periodic exchange of transport medium.
Real servo direct drive technology,...
...individual servo drives per printing unit...
...enables highest precision in printing register...
...due to extensive control options.
Maximum precision and die cutting especially for multi-out production.
Maximum four up due to a separate die cutting length correction.
For each row of outs in running direction,...
...the length can be set individually at the main control panel.
Fully automatic change of analogs roll in less than two minutes.
Highly automated setup processes...
...reduce the time required for the job changes to a minimum.
After a one-time fully automatic test run,...
...saleable products are produced.
Top vacuum stacker approach to zero defect production...
...through improved disposal of waste.
And these are just a few of the features...
...that identify both the CorruCUT high board line rotary die cutter...
...and the CorruFLEX Flexo Postprinter from Koenig & Bauer.
...as a technically leading solution.
Industry 4.0, 24/7 service support...
...and predictive maintenance guarantee maximum availability.
Innovation.
Stability.
Quality.
Both machines have already been successfully commissioned at customers...
...and are convincing not only in terms of quality but also performance.